Sleep quiet my child my little drow
your dreams invite tranquility now
cast in this cavern stone walls so secure the
web holds you tight through under dark night
and guardian spiders that tickle you feel with
gossamer threat weave our goddesses seal the
spider queen's children and so too your kin are
here to remind you that you shall not sin they
show you the scourge the snake headed with they
bite and they tear until she hears your prayer
there is no such blessing to the damned up above
those who've forsaken the spider queen's love
in their way lies weakness and unceasing
waste and if you would join them
then so be debased
and when hellfire orb looks down on your shame
your soul is burned bare she knows you're to blame
you'll live ever running you've no place to hide
and huddled in fear for there is no disguise
the sun it will burn you the cold snow will freeze
the hopelessness tumbles you down to your knees
and when you are broken to her you will pray
but she will not hear you you've thrown her away
and you'll find no companions to stand in our
way when we hunt you and fight you and torment
the plane you've chosen the weaklings of the
world up above who speak empty words and know not
Lloth's love no love will not save you from human
deceit nor from bearded dwarves nor elvish conceit
the spider queen shows us the one single way
there is only the night there is never the day
for strength does not stretch through drugs or
through leaf it bleeds from the roots that secure
us beneath deep in our hearts wrapped tight
in loth's web we sting her glory we sing so
whisper your love of your matron your mother
who teaches the way to your sisters and brother
brother i say there can only be one for if there
were two there couldn't be you then that silken
swaddle that tickling wreath would instead
be your death by the spider queen's teeth
sleep sound in the darkness
or burn in the light alone
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new benedict cumberbatch video no you're not
dreaming that is benedict cumberbatch starring in
a dungeons and dragons short film so i'll explain
what this is all about because obviously he's
all over the place with marvel doctor strange
2 multiverse of madness in spider-man 3 no way
home but if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos and we will
probably be getting that spider-man 3 no a home
trailer during the nba finals pretty soon but if
you're not huge on tabletop gaming dungeons and
dragons forgotten realms dragon lance any of that
stuff this short movie is meant to be a lullaby
telling the life story of Drizzt Do'Urden and one
of the most popular characters to spin out of the
forgotten realms universe the legend of Drizzt
the title of this movie is what the saga books
about him is called and there are many many books
by the end of this year in the next couple years
there'll be about 36 books featuring his character
i was a huge fan of the forgotten realms in the
dragonlance books back when i was in junior high
i read through all of his origin story there are a
couple different trilogies that feature him early
on and then they just became so popular that they
just continued writing new books in his series i
think my favorite trilogy of books is still the
dark elf trilogy telling his origin story but the
only autographed copies of books that i have are
actually the dragonlance chronicles autographed
by margaret weis so if you're not really familiar
with the dungeons and dragons brand those are
a bunch of different dimensions different story
universes within dungeons and dragons so forgotten
realms dragonlance now magic the gathering all
different story universes where a bunch of
different characters live sometimes there are
multi-dimensional crossovers for games but they
were all born out of the larger tabletop gaming
side of the business in the story campaigns
that were created for dungeons and dragons
way way back in the day like they had all these
custom campaigns then writers like ari salvatore
came along and he just happened to be writing
original stories inside the forgotten realms
universe so he's the one who created the Drizzt
character and gave him his backstory and all the
other companions that you see during his stories
so he's kind of like the george rr martin of the
forgotten realms universe the big difference
though is that he writes books at warp speed
compared to the pace that george rr martin
writes if we're ever going to see winds of winter
and i don't think we're even going to see dream
of spring in our lifetime but the reason why
they released this short movie now with benedict
cumberbatch is because of the virus lockdowns last
year and everything that happened people being
stuck inside their homes there was an explosion
of tabletop gaming as you would expect in wizards
of the coast sort of the brand that manages all
these different properties so that they had one
of their most profitable years ever in the history
of the company so this summer in 2021 they're
doing a lot of extra special celebratory stuff
involving the games and the stories of the books
there is a new book in the Drizzt series that
he's releasing in august this year they're also
releasing the dark alliance game on xbox game pass
that features Drizzt and all of his companions
the main heroes from the icewind dale trilogy
there's even a live-action dungeons and dragons
movie with chris pine that's in development
right now that they'll be filming real soon
and if you're a big magic the gathering fan
there's also going to be a big crossover with his
character in the icewind dale characters during an
upcoming set i'm not really big on magic the
gathering my little brother was back in the
day but obviously as we got older we kind of fell
off but the character Drizzt is a dark elf also
called a drow born in the complete darkness
of menzo berenson located in the underdark of
the world of forgotten realms the planet a vast
series of interconnected caves and passageways
they call his home the city of spiders because his
people the drow worship leloth the spider goddess
she's also referred to as the queen of spiders
but she's this immensely powerful cosmic entity
who's normally portrayed as an antagonist so funny
coincidence that benedict cumberbatch is starring
as a character who formally worshipped a spider
goddess and is going to be starring in spider-man
3 later this year drist is unusual amongst his
people and that one he's born a male the drow are
a matriarchal society in their goddess grants
the female clerics their worshipers way more
power their society is kind of like the extreme
version of game of thrones the social standing of
your house is a huge deal and power structure
imagine something like the red wedding from
game of thrones or the battle of the bastards
happening every single week in the underdark
the social standing of your house is a huge deal
in the overall power structure of their culture
with the most powerful families being granted the
most favors from their goddess the most magical
power the most influence Drizzt is born into a
relatively mid-level family but their society
values ambition above all so he has no brothers
only just a huge pack of very powerful sisters
as he grows up and they try to indoctrinate him
with the values of their society basically kill
or be killed live to make war amass more
power for your family for your goddess
he becomes disillusioned eventually rebels against
them turns against their ways and gets banished
to the underdark eventually he makes his way
to the surface to try and find a better way to
live his life which is where he encounters all
the main heroes from the icewind dale trilogy
so the way the books were written though the first
time you meet him is in the icelandale trilogy
that came first the crystal shard but it's after
he's already come to the surface he's much older
and it's later in his timeline so he just enters
the story as this mysterious dark elf ranger that
joins your party and you just slowly learn more
and more about him over the first three books
it was until right after that that the character
became hugely popular that r.a salvatore wrote
his origin story during the dark elf trilogy
of books and that's when you find out how he
was born where he grew up and what it was like so
like i said he's probably one of the most popular
characters to ever come out of the forgotten
realm story universe so even if you're not big
on tabletop gaming like i was never a really huge
dungeons and dragons tabletop gaming person when
i was younger but i was really into the books in
the story universe i know we mostly do marvel dc
videos talking about benedict cumberbatch's doctor
strange and doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness
but vin diesel groot inside the marvel universe
is probably one of the biggest tabletop gaming
geeks that you will find out there amongst the
celebrities of hollywood like this crazy popular
person super wealthy huge dungeons and dragons
nerd you may have seen videos with them doing
tabletop gaming with the critical role people or
other dungeons and dragons related integrations
so you would be amazed at how many big celebrities
out there are big on playing role playing games
but in terms of that live-action dungeons and
dragons movie they haven't announced which
characters they're doing from which story universe
or if they're going to be brand new characters but
right now we just know that it's starring chris
pine hugh grant michelle rodriguez justice smith
and they'll probably announce the rest of the cast
when they start filming pretty soon but the movie
is supposed to come out in 2023 so i'm gonna cross
my fingers and hope that it does well because i
feel like so many of those dungeons and dragon
stories forgotten realms dragonlance would make
amazing movies and they have tried to make movies
about them in the past like there was an animated
dragonlance movie a long time ago but it's really
hard to find and it didn't end up being very good
so once we start getting trailers for that i will
start doing videos for that movie but everyone
just post all your reactions in the comments
below and like i said we should be getting
that spider-man 3 no way home trailer pretty soon
i will be doing marvel loki episode videos that's
going to start in a couple weeks so make sure you
have alerts enabled for my channel so you don't
miss any of that while you wait for everything
click here for my brand new doctor strange 2
movie video all about shoe mcgorth and you can
click here for my brand new venom 2 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!